where does our desire to write come from
I think the desire to write is really
the desire to evolve or to um by
resolving an inner dilemma and uh and by
dilemma I mean um I really think that
the purpose of story is to reveal a
transformation and a transformation
really involves the resolution to a
dilemma and I think of a dilemma as a
problem that can't be solved without
creating a new problem there's two
ingredients to a dilemma powerful design
and a false belief think about that for
a second you've got you've got your
protagonist they've got this powerful
desire but they're also struggling with
a false belief so at the core of every
story is a protagonist that wants
something that's impossible to achieve
based on their current approach their
current identity does that make sense
yeah so um so I think the desire to
write is really the desire to resolve
olve our own dilemma I'll give you some
examples of dilemma let's say for
example uh Faith The Dilemma of faith is
powerful desire would be I want to
believe false belief would be give me
proof then I'll
believe uh uh success notice a powerful
desire would be I want ambition I want
to be successful the false belief will
be I will be successful when I make a
million dollars or whatever it is but
what we want is always outside of
ourselves success is something that
happens outside of myself uh uh belief
or faith is something that happens
outside of myself I need proof in order
to believe and so what makes story so
powerful is that uh story really is
about reframing our
relationship to that powerful desire in
other words uh true faith will only
occur when we let go go of our false
belief that I require proof in order to
believe true success will only occur
when I let go of my false belief that
success is incumbent upon some outward
or some external um uh validation and
true success can only come from within
so as human
beings our I believe our desire to write
is really about our desire to understand
ourselves in a deeper way writing is the
search for truth okay well this goes
back to what I was just saying about
about resolving a dilemma so when you
think about it um problems are
solved
um but dilemmas are resolved through a
shift in
perception problems don't make for
interesting stories like I'll give you
an example let's say I get a uh I get a
flat tire I call Triple they fix my tire
problem solved not an interesting story
but let's say I get a flat tire I'm out
in the desert and uh the the the AAA guy
drives 800 miles to save me and I'm
dying of
thirst and I discover that the triaa guy
is the is the guy who is the man who's
sleeping with my wife now I have a
dilemma I want to kill the man who's
here to save my life now that could be
an interesting story this drive back to
civilization all right so so um
when you wait a second this is going
your question was about the truth well
yeah writing us a search for truth is it
my truth or is it an existential truth
the world well what I'm getting at is
that the
truth is the Story begins with an idea
of the
truth and by the end of the story we've
reframed our relationship to that idea
of the truth so the truth might at the
beginning of the story might be I've
been betrayed but that's not the truth
that's the perhaps the fact or that's
that's that's my belief but by the end
of the story the truth might be that
um that I have not been a good husband
and that in in and that by being humbled
I'm able to see something that I wasn't
able to see at the beginning of the
story okay or what if you thought the
truth was that your wife was cheating on
you but in fact that was her nerell
brother and he needed money because he
had a gambling problem and she didn't
want to tell you and he's adopted and no
one ever told you about him in the
family and so the only thing that was
bad was that your wife didn't tell you
about a brother that they were ashamed
of because it didn't fit the family sort
of Dynamics okay and so what's the
what's the question so you thought the
truth was that your wife was cheating on
you but in fact she was not being honest
but it wasn't about that it was the fact
that she was concealing a family member
so it was a lie of omission I got it and
and and the reason she was doing that
was she was trying to protect her
brother or she was also putting on
errors maybe they felt shame you know
sometimes the black sheep of the family
quote unquote brings shame so the family
doesn't want to acknowledge that person
I got you so yeah so uh are are we
exploring whether or not this would be a
viable story or the the truth we're
going back to because you were saying
it's about truth so in a sense the truth
was faulty in that because your wife
wasn't actually being uh oh I see what
you're she was not cheating on you I'm
talking about Universal truths I'm not
talking about the truth as opposed to a
lie I'm talking about I'm talking about
a deeper understanding of oneself or the
world you follow like the TR the truth
the truth that sets me free isn't that
my wife confesses oh this was not a
lover this was a this was a this was my
brother the truth is about the theme all
right so the the the truth might so
let's say the theme is uh intimacy I
want intimacy with my wife but I suspect
that there's there's a secret there's
some wall up right and
so uh every so so the Dilemma of
intimacy for example might be powerful
desire I want intimacy and the false
belief
uh the false belief might be until my
wife tells me the truth I can never have
intimacy with her but here's the thing
there's probably a reason she's not
telling me the truth that has nothing to
do with her brother it has to do with
her fear that of of what whatever uh my
response will be if there's true
intimacy she would take the risk of
telling me this family secret do you
follow so so so the the the the it's
it's it's not that she's concealing the
truth it's why she's concealing the
truth story is about a search for
meaning okay okay and and every well-
told story we want the story to build in
meaning as it progresses all right every
every page should be more interesting
than the previous page because we're
becoming more invested in the
protagonist's Dilemma all right so if if
all if if the story was simply about uh
why is she lying um or pardon me if if
the story was just about she is lying
and I wonder if he's going to find the
truth that's the plot the plot isn't
going to get you to the end of the story
what's going to get us to the end of the
story is by reframing our relationship
to why she's lying and so both
characters are going to have to if if
the guy is the protagonist if the
husband is the
protagonist he's going to have to in
some
way um change or grow in order for for
him to understand what intimacy means
that Mak sense the plot is will he find
out the truth the theme is will he
reframe his relationship to what
intimacy means will he in some way
humble himself so that so so that she is
actually able to tell him the truth and
will will the the new sort of
equilibrium will the new relationship to
each other uh survive this this
disclosure interesting okay so it's not
about whether hiding a family remember
because she felt shame or she's sleeping
with the pool boy she it's it's because
of her relationship to being how you may
see her or or you you wanting to be a
better husband something like that right
here's the thing is that if all that
happens in the story is a protagonist
gets what they want our audience is
going to be disappointed what we care
about is the protagonist getting what
they need and and so we don't really
ultimately care about what they want if
Jimmy Stewart leaves Bedford fall at the
end of It's a Wonderful Life we're going
to be disappointed what we care about is
that he reframes his relationship to
what a wonderful life
means